si vous ne connaissez pas qu'une vais
vous connaissez forcément l'un de ses
succès avec j'aimerais trop ses débuts
avec à l'horizontale
[Musique]
keen'v a fait danser la france avec
plusieurs de ses tubes au début des
années 2010 en quelques années cet
auteur compositeur a accumulé pas moins
de huit disques de platine s'il est
aujourd'hui plus rare en radio l'artiste
avait lancé avec plein d'entrain une
nouvelle tournée intitulée thérapie tour
un spectacle qu'il devait présenter dans
toute la france après +25 tournée à
succès mais voilà malgré
l'investissement du chanteur et de ses
équipes pour réaliser le meilleur
spectacle possible
le public n'a pas été au rendez vous
c'est donc courageusement que sur les
réseaux sociaux l'artiste de 37 ans à
assumer cet échec et expliqué qu'il
avait décidé d'annuler la tournée je
fais cette petite vidéo propose
annonçait qu'il me tarde apitoie on
n'aura malheureusement pas lieu vous
savez pas été au rendez vous l'un que le
projet ne vous a pas plu avant de
conclure la voix chargée d'émotion au
bout de sa 5e tournée en six ans à
guichet fermé c'était peut-être
l'attendait trop c'était trop trop
ambitieux et je suis premier de tueurs
une décision difficile mais à laquelle
le chanteur a fait face avec franchise
et sans blâmer personne
une attitude bien rare dans ce milieu où
sauver les apparences et souvent plus
important que le reste les personnes qui
ont acheté un billet pour l'un des
concerts annulés parents ne peuvent en
obtenir le remboursement en se
rapprochant du lieu où du site de vente
et voilà il est très touché bien sûr
kind et parce qu'il aime son métier que
c'est un artiste voilà qui a toujours
cartonné mais je pense qu'il va revenir
très vite avec de nouveaux succès c'est
très dur pour un artiste pour un homme
d'assumer l'entière responsabilité
il ne rejette sa sur rien il dit je ne
vous ai pas plus vous n'avez pas aimé
mon album et mais c'est de ma faute
entière y reviendra plus fort j'ai
trouvé ça d'une dignité extrême d'une
émotion d'une franchise sublimera livre
super courageux très beaucoup d'humilité
moi je trouve ça très très très bon
effectivement il ya tellement d'éléments
de langage aujourd'hui dans le show
business quand on voit madonna qui dit
qu'elle va être proches de ceux de son
public avec un concert très intimiste en
fait non c'est très intimiste parce
qu'elle peut plus remplir des grandes
salles et donc je trouve que c'est
vraiment très très bien les fermetures
yombo j'ai dit que vraiment allumé t.cm
dabo langois de pointe cette décision là
parce qu'il a été très honnête inversant
le public ça oui mais c'est beau moi je
trouve franchement j'aime les mecs comme
ça moi avec isis voilà ce projet là n'a
pas marché alors via un tweet qui a
énormément fait parler c'est un tweet de
bfm tv
regardez puisqu'ils ont commenté cette
actu bfmtv et i l'on me regarder ma
demande
dans le truck bfm tv voilà mademoiselle
valérie l'a définitivement zapper est ce
que vous comprenez voilà qu'on rigole là
dessus ou pas du tout pioneer one way
ouais c'est une balle mais bon lui était
honnête il était il apparaît que son
coeur il faut une vanne pour paris le 22
août l'info est censé faire de l'info
c'est pas mal d'humour d'autant qu'il
prend beaucoup sur lui peut-être même
au-delà du raisonnable parce qu'on m'a
tenu un piquet de trois pages samedi sur
le marasme dans le milieu de la chanson
et des chanteurs et sur le fait que
beaucoup mais arrivait à peine à gagner
plus que la sueur contrairement aux
apparences et donc lui sans doute il ya
énormément de tourner deux chanteurs
voilà les abris dans le monde le
chanteur mène très connu et grandes
stars voilà qui ont du mal à remplir
leurs aînés on savoure éléments
extrêmement difficile et très difficile
ils sont très peu nombreux ils se
comptent sur les doigts des deux mains
ce qui a réussi sa rampe lyria bruel
bill folie angèle il est très peu de
gens mais non nous il ya soprano adjoul
soprano y agréer monsieur il ya date
jouira d'une dizaine oui voilà oui cela
m'a dit ah oui oui maintenant je veux
dire j'y passais 20 kb fmi une personne
qui est vraiment en charge totalement de
la partie internet de la partie twitter
de changer tout ça
parfois c'est impeut table sur les
doigts sûr qu'avec le titre dessel vides
attendait le chanteur franchement c'est
s'effacer méchant c'est pas très gentil
c'est gratuit mais ces chiens d un truc
c'est que souvent les services internet
sont décorrélés du service général nous
voilà public le magazine nous on a
toujours taper sur public.fr ici ça n'a
rien à voir avec public la magazine
auprès de l'erc le magazine sont très
sérieux on connaît la rédactrice en chef
qui est super meriem palomba c'est vrai
voilà et public.fr c'est un torchon
voici.fr c'est un torchon les mêmes je
sais pas les mêmes au magasin ça fait
mal aux vrais maghrébine jeudi au public
à public voilà et même à marianne que ça
où les gens qui nous regardent
vous vous êtes un journal voilà qui fait
votre travail voilà vous faites pour
l'aller les trucs bien et tout ce qui
est sur internet ça vous portent
préjudice vraiment aimé me donner un bon
exemple pour les gens comprennent
myriam pas d'embarquer dans l'émission
vendredi que vous produisez tpm people
elle fait l'émission avec nous et le
lendemain public.fr un échec d'audience
émission catastrophique je l'appelle du
kent est gonflé honteux payet tout une
femme et une emilie c'est pas moi c'est
bip point fr et je ne peux même pas le
faire enlever alors qu'elle est patronne
de la direction m'a gazé chauveau le dit
il du monde après frère c'est un torchon
voilà je vous le dis
il a maintenant moi et alors airs au
dessus de public.fr encore plus de la
merde c'est voici.fr c'est de la chasse
voilà en fait il cherche les mots qui
marchent alors vous avez mademoiselle
valérie zapper qui marchait ce jour là
et ça fait du plus techniques du
référencement
et c'est pareil pour certains sites
comme on l'a déjà dit quand vous mettez
hanouna ou polémique
vous faites des milliers de colons
méthane en appoint dans la gueule savez
quoi merci